[Musica]
è un grande onore essere qua davvero in
italia a parlare per poi in terra
d'abruzzi come avrebbe detto d'annunzio
poi a basta un bellissimo paese
gemellato comparto in australia
io ho vissuto tanto all'estero parlando
di estero
ho portato sempre un po d abruzzo con me
qui vedete una foto di quando ero in
america in california in silicon valley
andavo a ser fare con questa l'idea
insomma un'auto 83 che avevo comprato
scegliendo i colori sociali del pescara
calcio biancoazzurro piaceva tantissimo
[Applauso]
peccato è stata proprio questa moto un
po a darmi una svegliata perché è un
certo un giorno mi sono reso conto che
non tutti i giorni sono uguali una
macchina mi ha investito mi sono
risvegliato in ospedale
confuso commozione cerebrale e il
dottore mi dice signor di nicola
aspettiamo una frattura spinale
se sapete io penso fino a poche ore fa
osservare guida una moto
camminavo correvo e adesso mi si dice
che presente sarò paralizzato tutta la
vita poi per fortuna quella diagnosi si
è rivelata sbagliata però mi ha fatto
pensare c span ci penso spesso e mi
chiedo ma quello che sto facendo mi
piace cioè che cos'è importante per me
nella vita e ho anche pensato un detto
che mi diceva mia nonna di citarla del
tronto brava donna che riceva chi va
piano va sano e va lontano
però continua dicendo beh chi va forte
va alla morte io dico non ha pensato io
andavo ente che erano qui a san
francisco trapanese play eppure ho
rispetto quasi la vita quindi questo è
un proverbio modo di dire italiano che
penso sia molto sia antico oppure un po
tossico oggi specialmente in economia
del giorno d'oggi
io penso che un ragazzo specialmente
abruzzese poi il nostro motto è abruzzo
forte e gentile deve andare forte deve
pensare questo abruzzesi ma anche tutti
italiani pensare che quello che vuoi
pensi potete fare oggi non pensate
potete farlo domani non lo sapete non
siate così certi di questo
quindi vi dico cogliete l'opportunità
maniera concreta vi piace questa è una
ragazza
reti di uscire volete viaggiare vedere
l'america e prendete l'aereo è andato in
america odiati vostro lavoro lasciatelo
cercate un altro oppure create voi la
vostra compagnia non fermatevi non
fossilizzatevi e soprattutto cercate di
crescere come si può crescere oggi
beh in modo più semplice quello di
circondarvi di persone migliori di voi
sembra facile però l'abruzzo
specialmente a tanti esempi in questo
senso vi ricordate il pescara calcio mi
piace tanto e pescara calcio pescara
calcio io mi piace io me da bambino
suonato con grande pescara di galeone e
mi ricordo comunque anche adesso più
recentemente grande pescara di zeman
e guarda caso avete questi tre ragazzi
qua verratti immobile insigne e non
tutti nel grande pescara di zeman 2011
2012 vinsero la serie b però ventenni
impararono a un rene maestro zeman poi
hanno lasciato purtroppo pescara e
l'anno dopo infatti pescara un dato
tantissimo bene però loro sono cresciuti
sono andati in giro per il mondo hanno
cambiato squadre un immobile dortmund
verratti a paris saint germain hanno
imparato da grandi campioni come
ibrahimovic hanno giocato in champions
league sono andati dei grandi campioni e
poi e sono entrati il fulcro della
nazione italiana di oggi negli europei
sono questi adesso verrati un po
infortunato però sono loro le persone su
cui si basa la nostra nazionale e questo
è anche un invito che dico tutti quanti
se dovete diventare dei grandi campioni
giocare in champions league nel vostro
settore oltre quello calcistico
beh non è un problema andate all'estero
imparate io vengo da san nicolò a
tordino sant'atto campagne teramana sono
in america in silicon valley era per me
la champions league dell'informatica
sito a stanford lavorato a microsoft
ho fatto mi e start up e poi è
importante inter un grande
professionista
però poi c'è una cosa che non bisogna
dimenticare ricordati da dove venite
ricordatevi chi gli ha fatto crescere
sano e io per questo dico dopo che se
avete come acquisito competenze siete
cresciuti tornate e restituito con gli
interessi al paese che vi è piaciuto
questo è una cosa che credo sia
fondamentale
molta gente molti italiani vanno via
vanno all'estero poi non torno questo è
un po è brutto perché si perdono
competenze di perdono conoscenze la
gente si dimentica dove viene io cerco
invece di ridare qualcosa è una cosa
molto bella che porta avanti da 13 anni
è un piccolo premio in matematica agli
studenti abruzzesi scuola superiore
portò a 13 anni e nemmeno a farlo
apposta
l'ultima edizione la tredicesima
ottenuta domenica scorsa 6 giorni fa
tenuta online
quest'anno anche l'anno passato per via
della pandemia queste sono alcuni
ragazzi che hanno partecipato su google
nyt e posso dire guardate che sono
ragazzi bravissimi
cioè io ho girato il mondo visto
d'america ho visto anche un pò in cina
questi ragazzi forti ragazzi di teramo
chieti pescara avezzano gente molto
molto bravi e allora cosa mi piace
raccontarvi che alla fine di questa
prova se giorni fa ho parlato con i
migliori classificati in questo questa
prova di matematica basata sui test
d'ingresso dell'università americana tra
l'altro un ragazzo che ha vinto due anni
fa è stato accettato una top university
americana tra l'altro ragazzo di pescara
sono molto molto contento per lui
comunque parlando con alcuni questi
ragazzi se giorni fa
pato con uno questo ragazzo un ragazzo
di guardiagrele non siete paese montano
della majella in par l'inglese colui che
wii switch 15 possiamo rare inglese
richard sud
gli dico in inglese parlami di te quali
sono le tue passioni cosa ti piace fare
e lui mi dice in inglese matt high
school student alexandra lecce nice
no io gli dico di suo pungo a ma non mi
risponde
sha dong won web botanico mazzate ma
dove imparato il cinese e il mandarino
nemici ho imparato da solo da
autodidatta faccio il cameriere con dei
soldi che mi dà insomma il lavoro 17
anni farlo un ragazzo è lo investo in
queste in questa istruzione
cioè se il vasto folgorato di con altro
esempio un ragazzo di 18 anni gli atri
nel teramano stesse domande vi faccio
possiamo parlare inglese
le tue passioni cosa fai questo ti piace
fare mi dice lavoro mia pizzeria di mio
padre lo aiuto piacevolmente la
matematica ma anche creato un sito di e
commerce per vendere ma chat e
giapponese in america la mia reazione è
stata fredda è davvero fare sul serio
cioè io non so voi ma io a 18 anni se
pensavo a truccare motorino pensavo le
ragazze
questo ragazzo ha creato un business
intercontinentale della sua stanza ad
atri quindi queste sono cose che 20 mi
riempie il cuore e ho visto questi
ragazzi solamente bravi novizi tantino
secondo queste due ragazzi e vero tante
storie da raccontare troppo poco tempo
però quello che mi colpisce è che se
comparo questi ragazzi con i loro
coetanei americani 200 in california in
america i si dice cose yes you can you
rosa fantastica amenità varie molto
spesso molto vacue in italia cosa dice
un ragazzo bravo arca alla rasta pianta
chelsea dice dove pensi di andare a una
ragazza di lanciano all'epoca molti anni
fa quando dissi guarda un sogno in
america cercare un po di diventare un
professionista mi disse ma chi sono
queste velleità americane cioè questa è
anche una cosa purtroppo comune in
italia non so in abruzzo in italia ossia
non si pensa in alto si pensa un po da
sminuire le persone si pensa un po a
dire se inadeguato alla fine il ragazzo
ci crede cioè quando una fiammella
invece di farla ridere di più la sila si
soffoca ed è una cosa terribile perché
sapete prima ho parlato un incidente ma
a parte la paralisi però vincente magari
uno può avere le ferite si rimarginano
puoi romperti un braccio ce la fai
però non c'è una ferita che non si
rimargina quella nell'animo una di mondo
tirato in cui tu un ragazzo con tanta
potenzialità non lo fai emergere gli
tarpa le ali
quella una ferita che non si rimargina
più ed è terribile
io cerco i ragazzi di invogliarli a
pensare più in grande
a volare alto che questa è una frase mi
piace molto tra l'altro se voi ci
pensate anche un pò l'inno della regione
abruzzo una parola buona vola vola anche
un altro significato nella
nel nostro inno però mi piace dire
ragazzi volate alto
non fatevi dire cosa potete cosa non
potete fare e soprattutto rischiate
questa è una cosa importante che
un'operazione di capire a 18 anni
facendo contro ragazze giovane è un
rischio non prendere rischi specialmente
oggi col mondo e con l'economia globale
sta cambiando tanto è un'occasione per
un ragazzo cercare un po di avventurarsi
in terre sconosciute
certo è importante sentire consigli da
persone insomma un po più anziani
genitori nonni
insomma parenti però ragazzo di anche
capire una cosa che quel mondo dei
genitori dei nonni è un mondo ormai
vecchio morto che non tornerà più e
quindi il ragazzo e capire un poco è la
sua strada capire quello che sarà il
mondo tra 5 10 anni è perseguire tue
passioni e cercare un po di farsi strada
da se stesso non è facile
ovviamente però i rischi sono tanti
magari sbaglierai sicuramente sbaglierai
magari il ragazzo vi ho detto prima dei
bis est e intercontinentali di atri fare
quel business andrà male può essere però
se io faccio adesso mi metto un po nella
vendita informatica faccio cosiddetto
albero decisionale
se sbaglio da giovani anche succedere ma
alla fine ho avuto come la tua
esperienza ho imparato
sono cresciuto come cultura come
professionalità la prossima volta che
farò qualcosa da faro meglio e poi
riprovo cioè non sbagli non ti vangelo
mica ovviamente se invece vanno bene le
cose
a quel punto è anche migliorato non sono
andato alla cultura la tua professione
ma anche un po la tua ricchezza
monetaria il che non fa male
quindi questa è una cosa il consiglio
tanti ragazzi prendete rischi sbagliate
imparate per sé perseverate e c'è
un'altra cosa che mi piace adesso piace
citare un filosofo anzi 5 filosofi
italiani forse li conoscete i pugni
allora i pooh sono tanti forse il gruppo
musicale più bello più forte che
l'italia abbia mai stresso prevede sono
pareri però c'è una canzone anche se
molto
chi fermerà la musica forse molti di voi
la conoscono è una bellissima canzone 1
cala cantati d'allegria non ci si
sofferma molto sul testo
in italia le canzoni su cui guardiamo il
testo
specialmente sono quelle di battisti
mogol fenomenali sicuramente però questa
canzone a me piace molto leggere quello
che dice chi fermerà la musica quelli
che non si sbagliano quelli che non si
svegliano quelli che stanno nei porti a
tagliarsi le vele qui parliamo di remare
di andare verso in un orizzonte io la
dico altro che remare qui altro che
tagliarsi le vele
qui dobbiamo salvare spiegare le vele
andare verso un po li di nuovi questa è
un po la cosa importante e cioè cerco un
po di comunicare questi ragazzi perché
possono farlo non devono più trifi carsi
di fronte le scelte perché questa
canzone dice quelli che non si sbagliano
sono quelli che a mente non sbagliano
mai perché non tentano nemmeno cioè io
dico un ragazzo non temete critiche
perché ovviamente sbaglierete però
implorandoli provando e riprovando a
fine avrete successo sarete contenti
quello che fate non siate come dante
dice ghigna di gente proprio che non
sceglie che rimane pietrificata gente
insomma media
cercate di essere meglio di questo e
chiedevi sempre una domanda ho fatto
quello che amo
la risposta è sì allora vostra vita una
vita che è valsa la pena vivere
grazie
[Applauso]